someone in my family just put Kelly
Clarkson's Christmas album on in the
living room my gay agenda has finally
succeeded hey what's up guys it's June
which of course means one thing and one
thing only
it's Pride Month to celebrate my team
has gathered some iconic sweets for my
LGBTQ plus fans and I'm gonna read them
aloud now for the first time never seen
these so let's do this you don't choose
to be gay you listen to Kelly Clarkson
and babe do a cover of make you feel my
love and you have no other choice
that's awesome and by the way I love him
and we might be working on something I
don't know tell me why I remember every
single word to Kelly Clark since 2003
debut album but yet can't remember what
I did last weekend the reply to that was
Alexander gold because you're gay Sam
that's awesome I've done some pretty
bloody gaping x' in my time but being
dragged along to a professional dance
studio to learn a full-on routine to a
Kelly Clarkson Christmas album track
about diamonds and Tiffany's for carats
that's the song is right up there FML
loved it I love that Kelly Clarkson
covering Lady Gaga is gay right I love
Lady gaga I love her music it's fun to
sing y'all being it's Gay Pride Month I
wanted to say thank you for being an
awesome human and inspiration your
support for the gay community is
appreciated hashtag gay pride hashtag
thank you oh that's so nice the only
reason I know the lyrics to It's Raining
Men is because Kelly Clarkson sing it
during season one of Idol and I just
performed the most epic lip-synch for my
life in a bar in LA thanks to her and
that's what Gay Pride means to me
rainbow flag hashtag Kelly Clarkson I
remember singing that
it's awesome today I thought for a
moment that I wasn't gay and then I
listened to Kelly Clarkson's cover I'm
dancing on my own and after I dried my
eyes I can confirm that I'm 100%
homosexual that's awesome people are
funny
that's just funny gay culture is
spending your rainy days as a closeted
child staring out the window and
lip-synching to break away by Kelly
Clarkson oh I hate that anybody had to
you know not be themself for a while
that's the saddest part every time I
hear this but I love that now people
feel more comfortable and we're turning
into a society where everyone is welcome
someone in my family just put Kelly
Clarkson's Christmas album on in the
living room my gay agenda has finally
succeeded it's my favorite album I love
Christmas songs I love that album thank
you for listening family Kelly Clarkson
is doing more for gay rights than any
politician that's true sure there are
plenty of politicians trying to do that
but I just live I don't think you have
to be a politician to support everybody
and spread the word that's the cool
thing about social media as well like
you're able to like connect people like
right in their homes and and at their
fingertips all the time and you're able
to spread you know positivity and your
have a little spread love and kindness
that's that's where you don't have to be
a politician you have to be so many
famous to do that you can be anybody
that's the coolest part I love it at
Kelly Clarkson is the newest gay icon
the boys lover the girls love our shoes
she is exactly what LGBTQ people need I
hope she knows how many people find
comfort and safety in here oh she has
saved some of our lives
hashtag queen I am not that powerful but
thank you I do love being the vessel of
positivity and support so all right well
those those were I love reading I love
that people don't think I do but I do
read tweets from people and so thank you
so much to my lgbtq+ fans for all the
support for so many years I love y'all
and just keep being just awesome and
yourself and funny cuz I'm laughing
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going